hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast conversion of Group A
streptococcus
Confirmation testing from culture to
molecular automation workflow
improvement and anti microbial
stewardship presented by dr. Donna woke
she is a system director of clinical and
molecular biology at Geisinger
diagnostic medicine Institute
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab rats and all
the air moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by Gaius Warren
molecular for more information about our
sponsor visit them at WWE cooler die
Soren calm before I begin as I to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type the questions into
the drop-down box that appear on the
screen we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on a helpdesk button located on the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use that ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits without further ado please join
me now in welcoming our presenter dr.
wolf I will now turn the presentation
over to her welcome dr. bow thank you
dr. Valdes and welcome to everyone on
the phone line today I'm going to share
with you our thought processes and our
operational processes as we moved from
culture for group a streptococcus to
molecular testing and we will start by
going through the background the
guidelines that
describe the group a streptococcal
testing Geisinger is population health
and stewardship perspectives and some
examples of compliance work from our
physicians to our recommended testing
guidelines and then I'll give a little
peek into what I think may be coming
next for group a strep testing
we're very we're all very familiar with
group a streptococcus testing buttocks
epidemiology is actually quite
interesting we know that in the United
States complications are uncommon and
infection rates peak at about seven to
eight years of age and the Center for
Disease Control estimates that there are
about thirteen thousand cases of
invasive group a strep disease per year
and about 1,600 people will die due to
invasive disease the highest rates for
death are seen in infants in the elderly
and there are several million cases of
non-invasive illnesses every year the
World Health Organization estimates 111
million children in developing countries
get in potato from group a strep and
close to a half a million new cases of
acute rheumatic fever and 15.6 million
persons will come down with a Q
rheumatic fever in the course of their
life of the year
now group a strep sequelae are actually
still problematic in Pennsylvania in a
recent morbidity and mortality report
there was invasive group a strep disease
that was tracked to a common source and
that report talked about outbreaks in
Utah Hawaii New York and Pennsylvania so
work especially attuned to the invasive
nature of group a strep most people talk
about its relationship to the acute
rheumatic fever strains
however the invasive strains are really
equally or it's not more important in
our clinical laboratory practice and to
just focus on the acute rheumatic fever
is is narrow in terms of our perspective
for population health and so we're
looking at pharyngitis as a precursor to
perhaps more invasive disease
let's talk about pharyngitis that's the
most common thing that we experience
sore throat high temperatures counselor
X days cervical adenopathy these are all
very common symptom ology either from
viral origin or for from group a strep
and other causes and sore throat
the red book the pediatric red books
from 2015 has a an amazing scenario of
images that describe the different
diseases caused by group a strep in in
different populations around the world
and many of them occur in the United
States and this is the typical sort of
sore throat that you that people see
pharyngitis but also this cannot be
successfully distinguished from some
viral sources of sore throat
at Geisinger group a strep is seasonal
and so we see peaks of strep throat when
starting kind of when the children go
back to school in August and peaking
pretty much almost always with the peaks
of flu season and that is a cyclical
circumstance for us we have increased
flu testing we have increased group a
strep testing and of note we have 16
large clinic providers multi specialty
clinics who are up are the the purveyors
of most of our our testing and have over
50 tests submitted per month
now the current complications of group a
strep strep throat usually occur in
patients who are not treated with
antimicrobial agents so if someone
doesn't get tested or someone gets
tested and and has a false negative and
they're not treated this is where the
purulent complications can fit in group
a strep could cause flloyd sinusitis and
cellulitis which is a fairly
[Music]
painful disease this picture illustrates
bilateral cervical lymphadenitis and you
can really see it's kind of the chipmunk
cheeks so to speak
causing from the swollen glands from
that lymphadenitis from that infection
now non superlative complications of
group a strep are also common around the
world and less so in the United States
acute rheumatic fever and accrue cute
glomerular nephritis this is a four and
a half year old male with a strawberry
tongue of scarlet fever and a rash
typical of a group a strep infection
this is a these are skin lesions called
erythema margin autumn legions on the on
the back of a white male with a cute
formatic fever
this is a ten-year-old boy that
presented with something that we call
the subcutaneous nodules of rheumatic
fever on the left you can see those
nodules in his the inner side of his arm
and on the right you can actually see a
histopathology slide that shows what
those nodules look like the infiltration
of of white blood cells etc and this was
called an ash off body
and soft tissue infections are also very
common to coli and here we see a group a
strep in potato we see group a strep
facial cellulitis also very painful as
the orbital cellulitis here is a
erysipelas of the left cheek
and then finally the most severe are the
systemic complications of group a strep
this is an example of something called
purpura fulminant that occurs with the
skin after septicemia or group a strep a
blood blood infection this is a
petechial rash from a strep pyogenes or
group a strep septicemia these are
called pasty lines and these are
commonly seen with scarlet fever which
is systemic this is the circle in blue
here depicts a skin or a skin lesion
called erythema nodosum
here is a picture of a group a strep
cellulitis and arthritis in the left
ankle and the purple squiggly lines are
not part of the infection they're just
the markings to show the red inflamed
area of the cellulitis
this is a picture that actually shows
the degradation of the bone from a group
a strep osteomyelitis case and the arrow
shows the blackened out sort of
non-white areas where the erosion is
occurring
is a chest x-ray of a bilateral
pneumonia and pleural effusion due to
strep pyogenes in our own system we we
actually experience postpartum
streptococcus pyogenes outbreak in the
labor and delivery unit and this can
indeed occur in other labor and delivery
units there can be outbreaks of severe
strains and hospitals and schools and
daycare centers and camps in any place
that people congregate so this is not
always an isolated disease it can be
something related to an outbreak or
public health event now there are also
some possible links although they are
controversial and more well controlled
research studies and investigations are
needed but there are variants proposed
associations between group a strep
infection and sudden behaviors like
obsessive compulsive behaviors and rxe
and of OSA and tic disorders and this is
perhaps maybe the most controversial the
pediatric autoimmune neuropsychiatric
disorders associated with strep
infections or pandas so keep your eyes
on the literature for more emerging
information about these associations
and finally even sort of larger than a
systemic infection is the triggering of
the super antigens or the streptococcal
toxic shock syndrome and necrotizing
fasciitis this is the hand of a 14 year
old male with group a strep sepsis who
then went on to develop the scalded skin
sis syndrome and the discrimination of
his skin this is a necrotizing fasciitis
case and the inside arm close to the
shoulder from group a strep so I don't
need to convince anybody it actually is
a good reminder though to realize that
although we commonly see group a strep
associated with the throat it actually
has much more severe complications in
many in many mostly untreated patients
so what do the guidelines the clinical
guidelines tell us about laboratory
testing or about preclinical assessment
of group a strep and testing guidelines
worlder College of American Pathologists
actually favors the back-up of negative
rapid antigen testing or RA DTS for all
ages and the rapid antigen test is
really them are a really common kind of
physician office lab test that occurs at
the site of presentation at the point of
care or near the point of care and it is
an antigen antibody reaction and color
develops if there's an antigen antibody
that combines and the color is bound and
you see a positive reaction they reckon
the CA P recommends backing up the R
ADT's with a culture or additional test
because of the declining accuracy and
susceptibility of many of the rapid
antigens over time now PCR is not
specifically addressed in the CA VAP
micro inspection question number two
two one four zero but it's it definitely
can fall under what they call other
other tests and in that respect it's
been our perspective that we would we
would move to that and I'll explain why
as we move through the presentation
there is a consensus document in the
pediatric red book 2015 is the latest
version of that and there is a pediatric
consensus for testing children in the
United States lab they say laboratory
confirmation is required in children
without viral symptoms so they're
conceding to the fact that if a kid has
a flu a test then maybe that's positive
maybe maybe they don't have strep throat
but we know that we do get positive
combinations with strep and flukes
during the flu season they also
recommend that you collect samples by
vigorous swabbing on both tonsils in the
posterior pharynx and they do also say
that negative rapid antigen test from
children our culture they cite that the
false negative culture rates occur in
less than 10% of asymptomatic patients
when in attica throat swab is obtained
and that was actually true when the
first rapid strep test came on the
market and if I guess I think when is
not the right word but if the specimen
is adequately contained because as
you'll see later on if a specimen is
suboptimal the accuracy rates can draw
from 80 to 90 percent all the way down
to 56 and 80 to 86 percent and that
varies widely by the provider and
whoever is collecting the sample
European guidelines for strep pyogenes
have a overall consensus against the
backup culture if the rapid antigen is
performed the pro culture is not
necessarily not necessary even after a
negative rapid antigen for the diagnosis
of group a strep in children and adults
their guidelines does however point out
that other organisms like group strep
group C and G beta strep mycoplasma
pneumoniae and chlamydia fo and ammonia
can also cause sore throat has will
viral antigens so that's kind of two
four and one sort of against therefore
blatantly against and then the last one
we'll talk about is the infectious
disease Society of America which is both
for Anakin's there are some
contradictions when you read through the
entire guidelines so they say that in
children and adolescents negative rapid
antigen should be backed up by a trope
culture and that recommendation is
strong they do not mention PCR they also
say that routine use of the back of
throat culture for those with a negative
rapid antigen is not necessarily
necessary for adults under usual
circumstances and that is also a strong
recommendation and they cite the low
incident of group a stress pharyngitis
and adults and the risk which is low of
subsequent rheumatic fever which is
generally low in adults you know we know
that however then they go on to say the
physicians you may wish to ensure that
they are achieving maximum sensitivity
may continue to use conventional throat
culture to back up rapid antigen so
they're leaving the door open for the
providers to really determine when they
should or should not back up a negative
rapid strep test and here they're really
only talking about cultures
furthermore IDSA talks about diagnostic
studies for group a strep pharyngitis
are not indicated for children less than
three years old because again acute
rheumatic fever is rare you know we all
agree with that that acute rheumatic
fever is low in the United States at
this moment but then again most US
laboratories are backing up a negative
testing and and catching the false
negative or the false negatives with
some kind of a culture or PCR and so you
know labs are following this EAP
guideline whether or not that's
associated with our low acumen rheumatic
fever prevalence no one really knows it
could be strain related it could be
testing related and you know but but
nevertheless it's higher around the rest
of the world where backup is not as
consistently performed in the States
the other thing they say is that
children less than three years old who
have other risk factors such as older
siblings may be considered for testing
despite of their the former
recommendation and it's been a while
since I've been around and lots of
three-year-olds but I still think
there's very few of them who aren't in
some kind of contact with older kids and
so you know that this this doesn't give
us a whole lot of guidance for our
laboratory perspectives and our
initiatives in the laboratory but
nevertheless that's what's out there and
I this section with the rheumatic heart
disease map you can see in 1970 to 1990
the white sections of the map are places
where acute rheumatic fever was low and
the darker sections where it is higher
compare that to the bottom map which
depicts 1999 to 2011 we still see a lot
of white areas we see some changes in
areas
we really don't know if this is due the
string differences emerging in different
parts of the world or different testing
and reporting patterns but nevertheless
the United States remains relatively low
in rheumatic fever
now let's
about so then you know the guidelines
are we know the disease is severe the
guidelines are a little bit vague and
open-ended so what is the laboratory to
do well we look to our our mantra I
guess is kind of the word that we use to
describe population health and
antimicrobial stewardship for our
patients and from population health
concepts we know that invasive group a
strep disease is a much bigger risk for
us than acute rheumatic fever so we're
really focusing on invasive group a
strep that is associated with many of
the things that we see as common chronic
or comorbidities or chronic conditions
in today's patient population diabetes
skin breakdown of the elderly heart
disease smoking cancer alcoholism
immunosuppressed IV drug use and
dialysis so in our in our perspective
population health is defined as the
health outcomes of a group of
individuals including the distribution
of set outcomes within the group so
we're looking at not just the patient
that we're testing but in our area we
also insure and care for many of those
same family members many of those same
community members so we also look at
what's going on in a community and
what's the role of testing above and
beyond what we do for the immediate
single patient so our aim is to prevent
invasive disease which is high impact
and high cost and from our perspective
the issues are not the traditional
sequelae of group a strep but rather the
invasive infections necrotizing
fasciitis group a strep bloodstream
infections wound and skin and
soft-tissue infections and if you look
at the epidemiology of invasive group a
strep then what do we see well we see
that what if we if we look back to the
guidelines kids less than one
one and two to four where they're saying
no need to test these people unless
there's an association with older
children they actually you know start
out relatively high for invasive disease
if they're carriers they may have cuts
they're putting the fingers places maybe
they shouldn't be putting them and so we
do see back then it kind of dips in the
years that we're testing everyone and
then it swoops back up again as we as
the population ages so when while the
throat may heal on its own the sequela
associated with invasive disease
increases with age and all of those
comorbidities we talked about in the
previous slide from an antimicrobial
stewardship population in our outpatient
we rely on both viral and bacterial
testing especially in the elderly and
chronic diseases and in children
physicians often you use antibiotic
treatment for sore throat which is not
related to group a strep we know that
they the combination of having a viral
test and a group a strep test is useful
to our stewardship popular to our
stewardship approaches and our goal for
population health is to use the most
accurate and sensitive assets so that
our physicians can actually rely on the
laboratory test result and not have to
guess this a false negative is it's a
false positive what am I actually
dealing with and there's intense
pressure on particularly pediatricians
to prescribe something when a child and
their parents come into the doctor's
office so having that accurate test
information is actually a good
countermeasure for them to be able to
say look I trust the results of this
test your child does not need
antibiotics at this time etc and for us
the answer to that is PCR because it's
the most sensitive assay and and again
while culture misses around 10 percent
of the true positives for most PCR
assays you'll see we find that that's
somewhat higher and that is probably due
to the fact that
screaming children are very difficult
patients to get a good throat sample
from and so we see that wide variability
of accuracy based on sampling
populations now we were challenged by
our insurance company why we were doing
molecular testing when it's not even
required to have culture confirmation by
some of the consensus guidelines but we
push back with a letter that says will
the our consensus guidelines we
submitted the information about the
increasing invasive group a strep
disease in the aging and comorbid
populations and we we printed a summary
of the points of our letter in this
clinical microbiology newsletter which
is available online and probably from
multiple vendors of group a strep PCR
where we focus on those concepts and I'm
happy to say that as of 2014 our
insurance companies including our own
and and our and not our own products are
actually reimbursing for this testing
and so this is available for others who
are facing lack of reimbursement the
cost of several invasive diseases is
easily eats up more than what it takes
to test with a low cost PCR for group a
strep
and and as I alluded to before we also
made the case that all while rapid
antigen tests were originally greater
than 95% accurate now false negatives
are very common they're still fast but
sensitivity ranges from 56 to 86 and it
varies with the provider how did this
occur and why aren't people picking up
on this well you know bacteria mutate
and an antigen test picks up what it
picks up and so if it started out
missing 10% of the strains in your
particular community like they did when
the FDA released them many years ago
then the strains that are missed are
going to become the strains that perhaps
then circulate in your community so you
have that pressure plus you know they
just change for no reason there's
there's a lot of people that follow the
streptococcal strain and when that's
those strains change the antigen testing
is very slow to adapt if there's a
mutational change that causes a protein
the same thing happens with PCR but the
primers are easier to adapt than making
a brand new antigen for an FDA cleared
test and so you know this laboratory
testing pressure of getting rid of the
things that we can detect is positive
and leaving the things we can't detect
is positive and those infections then
spreading from people to people is a
consequence of it's just what happens in
a community so we made that case as well
and uh recent publications here for you
that are outlined in the clinical
microbiology newsletter and afterwards
give you some quite good information
about the processes of sensitivity and
accuracy of the rapid antigen test so
there's clear need for some kind of a
back up I'll be a culture or PCR then
University of Washington fared Fong &
Canas Dingell had a really nice report
where they did a retrospective analysis
of almost a thousand you know over seven
hundred adults greater than 13 years of
age and they actually follow these
people to show the benefit of testing
the negatives that the rapid antigen
negatives and finding the cases allowing
them to return to work more more quickly
and reducing opportunities for invasive
disease so that's also another good
reference
our positions doing following our
guidance well our provider compliance is
actually pretty good
better than I thought it would be and so
70 17 percent of tests are actually
positive or and most of them are tested
and positive and a few slipped through
the cracks oops
you know being coded as strep throat but
no test was ever performed but most of
them are tested that that accounts for
the first 17% and then the all of the
rest of the pie chart comes to us in the
laboratory and so
of the total we find 10% more on top of
the 17% of the positives that really
were pulled out by the rapid antigen so
it it ends up being much more than 10%
of the difference between the rapid
antigen if we were to look at that we do
have data on that and then 73 percent of
the whole remains negative even after
the PCR testing proportionally
and in our pediatric sites what we see
and maybe I shouldn't say much more but
would say some more we range between 6%
and 18% of the negative rapid antigen
samples we get actually do come up
positive and that ranges it's a little
bit higher in the pediatric sites and
also these are not adjusted for sample
size so some of the you know some of the
sites are actually contributing low
numbers and you know that may vary but
we actually still see some mixed peds
adult sites that still have that 18%
positive so we feel like we're offering
a good service picking up you know at
least five to near 20% more on top of
the already positive sort of 17% of the
samples we see getting those people
proper treatment stopping the spread of
group a strep in our communities and
transmitting it to other family members
and schools and and the like so we do
quite a bit of group a strep testing and
we need it to be fast even the backup to
be fast
not just the rapid antigen and so the
next part of this I'm going to describe
how we valid how we verified a
laboratory developed tests with a gas
group a strep ASR and the Janice
pipetting system for the dice orang
strep PCR and this was an abstract at
CVS several years ago
we use the laboratory-developed tests
right now on the PerkinElmer Janus and
the UI is on MDX instrument formerly the
integrated cycler
and I want to point out that this is a
laboratory developed tests because we're
performing this on the robot which is
not part of the ASR package and so part
of the reason why our insurance company
pushed back on us was because of this
ldt comment that we put in our results
per the CA p recommendation nevertheless
we felt it was still the right choice
for us and the assay has the usual
master mix primers internal control and
molecular water the instrument is lays
on MDX the
the simplex extraction and amplification
control is used along with the group a
strep prong repair and in this assay
extraction and amplification occurs at
once there's no separate nucleic acid
extraction step and the robot does all
the pipe cutting for us
our initial study design was actually
looking at the old groove a strep DNA
probe versus culture versus the dice or
now dice Oren strep test we actually
collected a special swab that copán made
for us here pictured in the left because
we realized if we verified the new test
on any swab which would have been ideal
then we didn't have the right swab for
our our clinics to perform the rapid
antigen so copán made a dual swap one of
each one is used for the rapid antigen
which keeps it as a wave test it keeps
it on label the other swab is played
with lot swab is placed in it any swab
and then sent to the laboratory for
testing so and they will provide this
swab to you and other customers I
understand why people are using this now
for the same reasons that we asked them
to develop it so it's actually a nice
way around not messing with the CLIA
waiver for the rapid traps
so why did we choose an LptA to go
through all this trouble well we have
high test volumes we found that
automation can help us reduce entry
errors there's less steps and this
custom swab was really the key to how we
could pull this off in our large 4 to 10
hospital 45 County footprint for our
population what we found was we had
improved performance over the DNA probe
by quite a bit and when we first looked
at it it looked like the the PCR
positive predictive value was quite low
there were a lot of false positives when
we actually arbitrated that with culture
for the most part we had enough sample
to arbitrate that we came out with very
good accuracy analytical sensitivity and
specificity of numbers that you can see
here under the arbitrated column so
performance was quite good the 90% limit
of detection was determined to be one
point five times ten to the third csu's
per mil and the 95% limit of detection
lands somewhere between that fifteen
hundred and fifteen thousand CF use per
milliliter comparing equally well and
still better than the culture methods
that were used in the comparison our
mean age in gender of our population was
kind of interesting because it did kind
of parrot what we're seeing with the CDC
[Music]
guideline for when you have invasive
disease and when people might be testing
so our providers are actually kind of
picking up on that we're pick we're
peaking in the pediatric age and we have
a bimodal distribution where we're
peaking again with samples between 50
and 60 years old
maybe they're testing their throat while
they're testing their skin samples etc
we add a mean age of 27.2 and when you
do your verification it's kind of
important that you do tests in the
population that you're actually going to
be testing in - whatever and you can
when we do see an increase female of
percentage all the time because the
caregiver type of relationship and the
close contact with females so there is
kind of a skew for females in the group
a strep world our reproducibility was
also very high the standard the
variability over 20 different days was
only point to law which is typical for
extracted PCRs and we were quite pleased
with this this just shows the cycle
threshold distribution which was really
a normal shaped distribution and we
tested the both a group a strep positive
control and a groupie negative control
was also was negative during that time
we tested a large variety of both
viruses and other bacteria found in the
throat and found you know nearly 100
percent specificity and a lakely I
believe it was 100 percent and then
clicked with the clinical samples
similar performance
additional things we looked at was
carryover and contamination we had none
during our testing period and we this
was years ago we still have never had a
group a strep contamination event in our
laboratory there were no interferences
dessert observed when we looked at our
internal control or some people call it
the inhibitor control so we didn't have
a lot of matrix effect and that shows by
that tight precision when we're looking
at the internal control and the cycle
threshold we start with specimen
stability 72 hours at room temperature
or refrigerated with each swab and with
the dry swab even if people and they
sometimes do put the wrong swab in the
wrong thing then we have to cancel the
rapid result but we verified the dry
swab it as well we just have to we have
a smaller window stability less than or
equal to 24 hours at room temperature or
refrigeration and then we cross
validated all the cyclers that we have
in our cycler bench for cross instrument
verification so in summary we were able
to show sensitivity of a hundred percent
with the arbitrated sampled specificity
of 98.2 and a total agreement over 98%
and showed to our own cells it is
possible to automate this assay and
using the jazz robot pipettor now i will
say that there when the when the janis
pipettor works it works very well when
there is maintenance or downtime the
the support for speed because of it
being more of a sort of a research focus
company is not quite where we would like
it and I'm just being fully transparent
we are happy that there's a new robot
coming from the essaouira that that may
have more of a clinical maintenance type
of turnaround time and downtime
parameters we're also happy that Group C
and G strep beta hemolytic is coming and
we do know that we have about 6.5
percent of our sample we were involved
in a kind of an epidemiology window
assessment where we found it six and a
half percent of our negative samples
actually had Group C and G we know that
that can be normal in a carrier
population so can group 8 stress for
that matter and so it's just another
piece of information that we're hoping
to add in this small sample set we found
that most of the people that were
positive had symptom ology of sore
throat fever headaches fatigue as the
top symptoms yes this could still be
viral but in combination with the viral
testing it may provide information
particularly for immunocompromised and
other compromised patients with
comorbidities where this might be an
important thing not only for the strep
but perhaps for subsequent invasive skin
infections which we know these organism
will cause and then finally you know we
we looked at many different options for
our PCR testing so there's an aluminum
method amplify you group a strep and
they have cng like Ladell via leer strep
a the roche molecular leo the quite l
lira simplex approve a strep direct the
accuracy in terms of analytical
sensitivity and specificity are all good
the turnaround times vary and so
everybody has to pick what they say
works best for their system there's a
number of choices that you can pick from
if you are interested in converting from
culture to molecular methods and then
finally what are we looking at in the
future well we're looking at
other things besides group a strep
peritonsillar abscess --is lemare's
disease and fusion bacteria and Vincents
angina and and what do we do with throat
cultures from people that have severe
comorbidities immunosuppression or a
history of rheumatic fever
do they need strain typing do they need
extra things that we would collaborate
with the Department of Health we also
look for a sore throat after travel in
Europe in particular and other parts of
the world where there have been some
rare desirous strains that are not
necessarily those that produce
diphtheria toxin in the classic sense
but they do cause severe stroke sore
throat and so this is a nice review that
I'll I'll close and leave you with in
the cid journal by Shulman at all that
goes through a list of the other
bacteria D G Group C and G beta strep
will be testing for our cattle bacterium
we do test for in our thro cultures and
hope to automate that in a molecular
assay keeping our eye on the literature
for crying bacteria a dip serious
strains and of course an easier way to
detect use of bacterium and other
anaerobes we only get the tip of the
iceberg for fuser bacteria
those that have developed lemare's
disease but there's probably a higher
population that perhaps we don't know
about and and although rare bioterrorism
agents like Frances Ella and your seniya
can cause sore throat and then combining
that with the other microbes we know the
viruses are associated mycoplasma
chlamydia fula and yeast so our future
goal is to pick the most sensitive and
comprehensive assay as possible to
support our population health
initiatives and to improve our patient
satisfaction ratings for our providers
in the field we know that when we can
give a diagnosis
people go home happier knowing what they
have then if they go home still not
knowing what they have and so with the
Press Ganey scores and everything that
we're doing it de louvre us to try to
make a diagnosis and in some cases
there's there's actual reimbursement
issues for an infection that can be
identified versus those that cannot be
and so that's something important to
look into your local region because that
varies sometimes region to region
so I thank you for your kind attention I
thank you for your interest in group a
strep and all that it has been and will
be and I'll close this session and take
any questions you may have thank you
very much and have a great day
thank you doctor vote for that
informative presentation and for your
important research we will now start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and click the send
button well answer as many questions as
we have time for so let's take a look at
our incoming questions from our audience
our first question dr. Volk is what are
the thoughts on using molecular method
as a first line strep test rather than a
confirmation test well I would love to
be able to do that we actually have some
molecular instruments out in our field
sites so to speak our large position
office practices in the community that
may be adaptable for for molecular group
a strep testing and so we're we're
looking at those as possibilities the
all of those sites right now have
medical technologists and so we are we
have piloted molecular testing with them
in the community and in they're doing
very well our next step is to kind of
try to understand if we moved it a step
further and what we're thinking of is
the phlebotomist who are doing home
healthcare or who are there in the
smaller clinics where there's no medical
technologist who may be able to take a
throat swab from a nurse collect and
actually run the tests we find that we
have very good compliance with point of
care testing with our full botanist and
it doesn't seem cost
beneficial to tempt to have a nurse or
even a pharmacist to do point-of-care
testing when our phlebotomists actually
do a much better job so we're trying to
keep the laboratory focus what the
providers do what they do and then we're
looking at on-site group a strep testing
in the future we don't really have that
nailed in to what platform we might be
using yet but it is definitely something
that we're considering and you know we
really have to look at the cost in the
economics of doing that we've had a lot
of success with our on-site flu testing
in reducing the inappropriate number of
prescriptions for anti influenza and we
we hope that we could pilot some other
programs to look at doing that for
inappropriate antibiotics for group a
strep so there's a lot of things on
horizon and we're looking at the
literature and our own pilot processes
to make a final decision on that
thank you
dr. book our next question coming in why
did you validate an LD T instead of
using an FDA cleared molecular test the
thing for us was the ability to batch
and robota size the process so we do
over 30,000 close to 40,000 group a
strep test a year and those are the ones
that are negative so we have a very high
volume we've run that test three times a
day with careers that are delivering
specimens every four hours to the
central laboratory and so we test twice
on second shift than once in the morning
so that when the providers come into the
office the next day their backup tests
are there and ready for the phone calls
to be made to the probe to the patient's
so it was really a volume and automation
type of decision and the culture
processes are just too slow for people
anymore from our perspective we get a
lot of patient dissatisfaction waiting
for the incubation to occur and also we
were using the old DNA probe before we
were already doing molecular test day
and that was running its useful life and
and kind of some settings so we needed a
new tool that was high throughput and we
chose the PCR and in terms of that
verifying the LBT we're very comfortable
verifying that and you know it is
something that you need to talk to your
insurance providers about once we gave
them the data to support it they
actually agreed that it was a good idea
in our setting and so each each
geography varies
thank you I also want to thank our
audience and members for their incoming
questions and remind them that any
questions not answer today will be
answered via email we have time for a
couple more questions here's our next
one how do you justify the higher cost
of molecular testing compared to culture
well you know when when you actually do
the math on a method like this that
doesn't have the cost of extraction
built into it and you consider all the
hands-on times that occur when a strip
is looked at perhaps subculture maybe a
latex fast and you you put that all
together the high throughput of this
actually makes the cost not as
prohibitive as you may think now in
terms of the former question is do you
know what I like to just have this be
the primary test yes because you know
the rapid antigen is an additional cost
and while it's not a huge cost it would
be nice to just standardize and pick one
task and move forward so we really
haven't got any major pushback in terms
of reimbursement from the insurance
companies that we work with and so it
were not really passing this on to the
patients in most cases we do have a
caveat for people that perhaps are
uninsured and can't pay and we can
sometimes make accommodations for that
but the cost of this test isn't very
high compared to other molecular tests
and so really don't come across that
plus many of our people are are covered
with insurance in our region because of
the low cost health plan that we offer
which is more preventive and so we don't
have a huge proportion of uninsured
patients in our population again that
varies by geography right thank you we
have time for one more question do you
test group G and C strep with Group A on
all samples or are they ordered
separately
that's our intent moving forward we
don't at this time we still offer a
throw culture for group beta hemolytic
groups eg Arkana bacterium and other
bacterial pathogens and in cases of
lemare's disease we will do an anaerobic
culture on a throat but what we all of
that all the differences in
methodologies is a human cost for our
technologists and we hope to be able to
put them all together as best we can and
try to keep the price at a price point
that is not going to be onerous to our
patients because for the people who are
aged or have comorbidities for it could
be experiences a sore throat by these
alternate pathogens it would be better
from my perspective to have a
one-and-done syndromic panel where we
could test for all of those and that's
what we hope to be able to do in the
future
dr. woke thank you again for your
presentation and for your important
research I'd also like to thank dinosaur
on molecular for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go audience I want to remind you all
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through July of
2018 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and thank
you for joining us today we hope to see
you again soon
bye bye